[Music]
now you know a lot of fans are
campaigning for you right now to be in
marvel as blade what's that face for
would you be down to take on a role
following in Wesley Snipes footsteps you
know a role like that for me would
require a serious transformation but III
want to see Wesley Snipes come back in
the role I think it would be good to see
in the helm blade again I'll be good it
looks like John boyega may be leaving
that iconic role - Wesley Snipes a role
John did say yes to go playing Jake
Pentecost and Pacific Rim uprising this
is our time this is our chance to make a
difference now you're playing
essentially you just helped us son in
this film
did you go did you get any tips from him
did he congratulate you at all I know I
know I'm smiling because I bet I'll be
think it was it just it just probably
think he a you know going through your
thing man you know I mean but no he sent
a nice message congratulating me and you
are pulling double duty in this sequel
as a producer and an actor what went
into it yeah definitely there is
pressure you know you want to make a
story that's dynamic enough to bring in
a new audience as well as please the
audience I love Pacific Rim one at the
same time you know this is a big massive
movie that we didn't really have as much
time to shoot so it was definitely a
ballsy move you know this is something
that we took a risk last thing obviously
everyone is talking Star Wars next why
is your first Star Wars memory as a
child I remember getting a dolphin or
action figure with a happy milk you know
and passed down by my sister when the
prequels were coming out and so I just
remember having this action figure that
I thought was really cool but I knew
nothing about the world again which came
from so my first earliest ever Star Wars
I love that
you